a
del consejo regional indígena del cauca
ya no vende al público sus emblemáticas
pañoletas temen la infiltración en sus
minas y en sus territorios operaciones
de inteligencia que aseguran estar
viviendo en el paro nacional durante las
manifestaciones han capturado a
distintas personas armadas que habrían
atacado a los civiles en el centro de la
plaza de la universidad del valle en una
silla y frente a toda la comunidad
sientan a uno acusado
aseguran que ha reconocido ser un
policía infiltrado
la custodia territorial humanitaria que
hace nuestro esquivo eternas guardias
indígenas y nuestras autoridades y que
hoy se le entregas sano y salvo
los garantes deben entregarlo porque es
un funcionario público para muchos
presentes este trato no corresponde con
el que los indígenas reciben cuando son
detenidos por la fuerza pública
[Música]
las naciones unidas- la defensoría del
pueblo en la procuraduría acuden a
recibirlo antes de entregarlo a la
fiscalía manifestando que nosotros como
defensoría somos totalmente respetuosos
por favor todo este proceso está
recogido en la ley 246 de la
constitución que otorga derecho propio y
derecho mayor a los usos y costumbres
del pueblo indígena la jurisdicción
especial indígena es las facultades que
después de luchas que dieron los mayores
cuando se constituyó la constitución de
y finalmente el acusado es entregado a
las organizaciones humanitarias la minga
cumple así con la jurisdicción especial
sin embargo la alerta continúa entre la
guardia indígena con el fin de evitar
nuevas infiltraciones durante el paro
nacional
[Aplausos]